le côlon tour une visite guidée d'un
côlon géant devant la caisse primaire
d'assurance maladie des yvelines
une structure gonflable pour informer
les visiteurs sur le cancer colorectal
une pathologie formés à travers des
polypes des tumeur bénigne
vous avez un polype qui est très grand
avec une excroissance qui est vraiment
retirer alors vous avez plusieurs stades
soit vous avez une excroissance qui
vient bien à l'intérieur du polype fin
du côlon pardon soit vous avez un polype
qui reste bien bien ancrée sur la paroi
de l'intestin
on n'a pas l'habitude vraiment de se
promener dans un colon et en même temps
ça permet de de valeur d'avoir des
informations de discuter d'avoir des
renseignements et puis finalement
d'enlever toute peur par rapport à août
est justement ce que j'ai appris
aujourd'hui c'est que neuf cancers sur
10 peuvent être justement je dirais
geri entre guillemets si on le prend
assez tôt donc du coup c'est important
de relayer cette information
une initiative organisée avec la ligue
contre le cancer et la demie des
associations engagées dans la promotion
du dépistage auprès des yvelinois
j'entre 50 et 74 ans alors que 43 mille
personnes sont diagnostiquées atteints
du cancer du côlon chaque année c'est
important parce que ça évite de
développer des pathologies qui peuvent
être lourdes et compliquées et voilà
donc c'est en amont et et en voilà c'est
important important qu'on le voit très
vite et ce qui était important c'est de
pouvoir créer un événement ludique
visuel avec du partage des échanges pour
dédramatiser cette maladie et ce
dépistage
selon les données de la demie près de
cent mille événements participent au
dépistage entre juin 2015 et met à 2017